in Vietnam's Southern mikong Delta
Region rice is at the center of life and
provides livelihood for
thousands most of the country's rice
comes from here but life is changing
erosion and drought threaten the fertile
land both increase the amount of salt in
the rice patties and contaminate
crops there's been a lot more unseasonal
rain I feel it is the most challenging
time because of climate change when it
rains it pours when it's sunny it's
really sunny this period is quite
difficult new used to grow rice but like
many farmers in the area the erratic
weather patterns forced him to switch to
other crops despite the elino phenomenon
Vietnam's rice exports hit a record high
in 2023 prices soared after India banned
exports of the grain farmers were
instructed to start planting earlier
than normal in part to help mitigate at
some of the effects of elino Vietnam is
among the world's top rice producers and
the mikong Delta area is often called
the country's Rice Bowl but authorities
will seek to reduce exports in coming
years partly in response to challenging
weather
conditions Indonesia's West Java rusia
says the soil is so dry and hard it's
damaging his
tractor he has worked in rice fields
since the early
1980s
in the past the weather was very good by
October and November there would already
be a lot of rain and the pest would
usually come in August or September but
now they are
unpredictable scientists say finding
resilient crop varieties is essential as
the weather becomes more
unpredictable uh during Alo uh the uh
Pest and also disase um attack will
increase climate change uh will uh have
impact on uh saltwater intrusion into
the party rice world yeah party rice
will uh decrease the productivity or
even we cannot PL on the soil
Indonesia's president Joko wodo has
ordered the military to help farmers
plant rice in areas where rain has
started to fall to mitigate the delay
caused by the dry weather meanwhile
rusia is taking odd jobs to survive he
says he's tired of plowing Dusty fields
and looking up the clouds waiting for
the rain Jessica Washington aljazera
West Java
Indonesia make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer